un desafiante donald trump ya piensa en
las elecciones de 2024
de hecho como ustedes saben ellos acaban
de perder la casa blanca rural
pero quién sabe quién sabe yo podría
incluso decidir ganarles por tercera vez
han pasado menos de seis semanas desde
que dejó la casa blanca y el ex
mandatario asegura que el camino que
comenzó en 2018 está lejos de terminar
en su discurso de clausura de la
conferencia de acción política
conservadora
el magnate consolidó su estatus como
líder indiscutible de un fracturado
partido republicano y negó que fuera a
crear un nuevo movimiento político
[Aplausos]
ellos han estado diciendo van a crear un
nuevo partido
nosotros tenemos el partido republicano
va a estar unido y fuerte como nunca
antes pero fue su sucesor joe biden
quien apenas lleva poco más de un mes en
el cargo el principal protagonista de su
intervención y se llevó todas las
críticas
joe biden ha tenido el primer mes más
desastroso de cualquier presidente en la
historia moderna
las políticas migratorias el manejo del
plan de vacunación el regreso al acuerdo
de parís y la suspensión de la salida de
la organización mundial de la salud han
sido según trump algunos de los
desaciertos de las primeras seis semanas
del líder demócrata en el poder
[Música]